und das hat uns alle hier aufgerüttelt
was und wie unsere Reporterin aus
Frankfurt vor wenigen Stunden hier bei
Bild live berichtet hat unsere
Reporterin Jessica ferley die nach einer
neuen Schießerei ins Frankfurter
Bahnhofsviertel gefahren ist mal wieder
und verzweifelt an ihrer Stadt die dort
immer mehr verkommt immer mehr zu No-Go
area wird
ich liebe meine Stadt wirklich aber das
Bahnhofsviertel ist wirklich so ein
Viertel wo ich sage ich fühle mich hier
nicht sicher als Frau schon gar nicht es
ist das Eingang zu unserer Stadt es ist
eine Katastrophe diese die die komplette
Lage ist hier einfach ja ich liebe meine
Stadt aber das wird eine Katastrophe
hier im Bahnhofsviertel das also waren
die Worte von meiner reporterkollegin
Jessica ferleite dort in Frankfurt im
Bahnhofsviertel auch ein Hilferuf warum
ändert sich hier nichts warum lässt man
das Bahnhofsviertel so zu einer No-Go
area verkommen und der Anlass für diese
Reportage ja der war das hier eine neue
Schießerei in diesem Hotel dort in dem
Bahnhofsviertel in der Moselstraße ganz
genau Einsatz von Polizei Spezialkräften
bedrohungslager am Ende erschießten
Polizisten Mann und es ist ja immer noch
nicht ganz klar was genau dort
vorgefallen ist Schüsse Polizeigewalt
Drogenexzesse Alltag im Frankfurter
Bahnhofsviertel
zusammengeschlagen ausgeraubt liegen
gelassen immer wieder macht das
Frankfurter Bahnhofsviertel bundesweit
Schlagzeilen erst vor zwei Wochen
schockierte dieses Handy-Video
Deutschland ein Mann wird umzingelt und
mit voller Wucht ins Gesicht geschlagen
er liegt bewusstlos am Boden dann wird
der ausgeraubt das Frankfurter
Bahnhofsviertel Hotspot der Heroin und
crack-szene ein Brennpunkt für Gewalt
Prostitution und Drogen auf offener
Straße werden Drogen gespritzt
geschnopft und gedealt und immer wieder
eskaliert die Situation diese Woche dann
der traurige Höhepunkt spezialkräfte der
Polizei Rücken am Dienstagmorgen an
erschießen einen 23-jährigen in diesem
Hotel was sich hier genau abspielte
unklar fest steht nur als die
Spezialkräfte anrücken eskaliert die
Lage Schüsse der 23-Jährige
sollen seinen schweren Verletzungen
Vorfälle wie diese sind der Grund dafür
weshalb Bürger das Bahnhofsviertel von
Frankfurt schon lange meiden die Gegend
wird immer mehr zu No-Go-Area
Mitarbeiter der Müllbeseitigung können
teilweise nur unter Polizeischutz ihre
Arbeit im Bahnhofsviertel verrichten
unglaubliche Zustände die Frankfurter
sind entsetzt ich liebe meine Stadt aber
ich schäme mich so ein bisschen für
dieses Viertel hier ich fühle mich ja
auch nicht sicher die Junkies lauern so
ein bisschen in den Ecken wenn man
reinkommt der eine schießt sich gerade
was in die Armbeuge der andere macht ein
Nickerchen auf dem E-Scooter vor dem
Kiosken werden Substanzen ausgetauscht
sich durch die Nase gezogen das
Bahnhofsviertel eins das Tor zur Stadt
heute das Tor zur Hölle es sind
verstörende Bilder die uns immer wieder
aus dem Frankfurter Bahnhofsviertel
erreichen Bilder die schockieren
wie viel muss hier noch passieren
[Musik]